They have control in the House.
The American people need to know
that they don't have the courage
to do anything
to save the lives of children
who are parents need support.
That when you look at that
data, you're not looking at their
you know, your
you know, kind of what it could be.
But I'm listening to what I'm saying.
That's why the children are dying.
I know I've got, you know, children
arming teachers that's going on.
I was a teacher.
I was a school counselor.
I was a middle school principal.
I was in cafeterias.
Every kid allowed every day
in my country.
There's never been a shooting.
I never get a shooting.
It's time.
We've got guns here to protect us.
And as I believe,
the president should have
somebody to protect them.